Це фірменний знак канцлерки Німеччини Анґели Меркель. Як і у цього ромба з чотирма кутами,
у діях Анґели Меркель за 15 років її правління у ФРН можна виділити чотири основні внески для України -  два позитиви і два негативи.
Анґела Меркель стала канцлеркою у листопаді 2005-го і протягом перших двох строків її урядування Україна не була топ-темою в порядку денному ФРН.
Анґела Меркель застала чотирьох лідерів України: Віктора Ющенка, Віктора Януковича, Петра Порошенка і нині Володимира Зеленського.
Під час президентства Ющенка та Януковича у німецько-українських відносинах не було жодних вагомих проривів.
До 2014 року Україна для німецьких політиків та суспільства загалом була пострадянською країною, де панують олігархи та корумповані політичні еліти.
Євромайдан, анексія Криму Росією та війна на Донбасі кардинально змінили ситуацію.
Україна вийшла зі "сліпої зони" Німеччини, й Анґела Меркель, на думку оглядачів, стала саме тією політичною фігурою,
яка опинилася у правильному місці та в правильний час не лише для українсько-німецької історії, а й для світової.
Жоден із документів не зобов’язував Німеччину підтримувати територіальну цілісність та суверенітет України
або ж бути посередником між Україною та Росією після агресії Москви на початку 2014-го.
Це очікували радше від Сполучених Штатів і Великобританії, які мали б бути активнішими, зважаючи на їхні підписи під Будапештським меморандумом.
Але саме Берлін став головним гравцем. Міжнародні експерти часто називають Німеччину reluctant leader,
тобто "неохочим лідером", для якого реакція на дії Росії стала вимушеним, а не обов’язковим кроком для захисту
не стільки інтересів України, скільки міжнародного права та безпекового порядку в Європі.
Україна заслужила усю можливу підтримку для успішного економічного просування і на шляху до миру.
І Німеччина продовжить надавати цю підтримку.
Саме завдяки особисто Меркель вдалося стримати Росію на трьох рівнях.
Перший- у рамках урядової коаліції та серед бізнес-спільноти, де є чимало тих, хто ставить під сумнів доцільність санкцій проти Росії.
Другий рівень - вплив на країни Європейського Союзу.
Меркель відігравала ключову роль у запровадженні, продовженні та посиленні санкцій Євросоюзу проти Росії.
Звісно, ці заходи ЄС могли б бути ще більш серйозними, але без наполегливості канцлерки Німеччини
санкційний режим міг виглядати слабшим і не тривати всі ці роки.
І третій рівень- вплив безпосередньо на Росію й особисто на Володимира Путіна,
навіть якщо Меркель часто критикували за її розмови з господарем Кремля з огляду на його агресивну політику щодо України.
Меркель у прямому розумінні недосипала через Україну.
Особливо під час виснажливих переговорів у Мінську в лютому 2015-го. Канцлерка вела перемовини упродовж 17 годин.
Завдяки позиції Меркель вдалося зупинити гарячу фазу бойових дій на Донбасі, хоча питання остаточного закінчення війни ще залишається відкритим.
Не таким позитивним для України натомість став внесок Анґели Меркель у квітні 2008-го.
Канцлерка ФРН прибула на саміт НАТО в Бухаресті. Тоді Україні та Грузії відмовили в отриманні Плану дій щодо членства в Альянсі.
Роль канцлерки Німеччини була однією з ключових.
За словами учасників тих перемовин, Меркель виступила проти ПДЧ для України, дослухавшись до аргументів Путіна.
Нині чимало політиків та експертів вважають, що саме блокування євроатлантичної інтеграції України та Грузії
розв’язало Росії руки для агресії в Грузії у 2008 році і потім в Україні у 2014-му.
Загалом питання інтеграції в НАТО - один з найбільших подразників у відносинах між Києвом та Берліном.
Переважна більшість німецьких політиків виступають проти членства України в Альянсі, щоб не псувати відносини з Росією.
Крім того, подібні настрої панують і у німецькому суспільстві.
За даними соцопитування Німецького фонду Маршалла, у 2014 році на запитання, чи потрібно запропонувати Україні членство в НАТО,
67 відсотків опитаних німців сказали "ні". Це був найбільший рівень несприйняття серед жителів країн-членів Альянсу.
Нині, за даними соцопитування на замовлення центру "Нова Європа", оприлюдненого у листопаді 2020 року,
за членство України тільки в НАТО виступають лише 15 відсотків опитаних німців, а за членство України і в НАТО, і в ЄС - 16 відсотків.
Дослідників обнадіює, що підтримка членства України в ЄС та НАТО набагато вища серед молоді,
ніж серед представників старшого покоління, тож ситуація з часом може змінитися на користь Києва.
Підтримка німецьким урядом проєкту "Північний потік-2" - нині одне з головних непорозумінь у відносинах Києва і Берліна.
Цей газопровід має пройти дном Балтійського моря і транспортувати газ з Росії до Німеччини, а звідти - на решту європейського ринку.
Таким чином Росія намагається знизити залежність від транзиту газу через Україну.
Меркель невпинно переконує, що "Північний потік-2" - це економічний проєкт і не треба його політизувати.
Ми вважаємо, що "Північний потік-2" повинен бути завершений.
Це проєкт, який втілюють представники економіки Росії та Європи.
Натомість Україна, Польща, країни Балтії та особливо США вважають, що ЄС через цю трубу стає енергетично залежним від Росії.
Вашингтон навіть запровадив санкції, щоб не допустити відкриття "Північного потоку-2", який перебуває на фінальній стадії будівництва.
Попри невдоволення Києва підтримкою німецьким урядом "Північного потоку-2", а також відновлення повноважень російської делегації у ПАРЄ,
яке теж підтримав Берлін, відносини України й Німеччини нині значно кращі, ніж на початку канцлерства Меркель та двосторонніх відносин загалом.
Українцям є з ким порівнювати: з одного боку, Меркель, яка доклала чимало зусиль для допомоги Україні у стримуванні агресії Росії,
а з іншого - попередник Меркель, ексканцлер Шредер - друг Путіна, який нині працює на "Газпром".
Крім того, Німеччина- третій найбільший донор України після ЄС у цілому і Сполучених Штатів Америки.
Німці інвестували сотні мільйонів євро в українські реформи, а також консультували український уряд, особливо у питаннях децентралізації.
Українці також довіряють Меркель. За даними різних соцопитувань,
канцлерка ФРН користується найбільшою суспільною підтримкою порівняно з лідерами інших країн.
Окремі українські оглядачі припускають, що нині Меркель усвідомила помилковість своїх кроків щодо Росії
та надмірну довірливість, яка не виправдалася, стосовно Путіна.
І це змушує її більш уважно формувати свої підходи до тих країн, які постраждали від російської агресивної політики.
Мовляв, для Меркель підтримка України стала чимось на зразок справи честі, щоб показати можливість історій успіху на пострадянському просторі.